j'ai vraiment des demandes hyper
farfelues des demandes des dinguerie des
dingues vraiment genre des fois j'ai des
mecs et tout ils m'envoient leur leur
[Musique]
moi j'ai grandi uniquement avec mon père
j'ai jamais connu ma mère et mon père sa
profession était bodyguard lorsqu'il
montrait les photos avec les célébrités
qui protégeaient et ben moi ça m'a
vraiment donné envie justement d'être
cette célébrité et c'est pour ça que bah
le monde du showbiz ça m'a toujours
attiré moi mon papa il est vraiment très
large d'esprit voilà il m'aime beaucoup
je l'aime beaucoup on est très fusionnel
par contre il m'a pas poussé à faire ça
mais il me juge pas c'est à dire il
accepte ce que je fais il est au courant
de tout ce que je fais mes apparitions
j'étais PMP voilà mon père c'est
vraiment un soutien mon enfance a été
heureuse jusqu'à un moment donné où
pendant l'adolescence j'ai eu vraiment
une crise un peu de rébellion ou
vraiment mon père le pauvre j'ai fait
vraiment la misère je faisais n'importe
quoi je sortais tous les soirs en soirée
vraiment je fumais aujourd'hui je ne
fume plus j'ai arrêté l'école assez
jeune je pense je devais avoir 17 ans
j'ai fait une formation de de coiffeuse
un truc comme ça et donc du coup j'ai
été coiffeuse pendant deux semaines et
et c'est fut vraiment un fiasco je
devais enfin j'avais ma patronne de
l'époque qui m'avait appris à faire des
mélanges et tout de défrisages et donc
du coup j'avais mis trop d'Occident il
me semble c'était un produit comme ça et
donc du coup bah après je vais appliquer
des prisages et après je vois genre des
la masse de cheveux en train de tomber
j'étais en train de paniquer et là j'ai
ma patronne qui a commencé à crier et
j'ai su que c'était pas fait pour moi
alors du coup comment j'ai fait pour
percer c'est simple moi voilà comme je
vous ai dit j'ai toujours voulu être
célèbre maintenant c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque j'avais mis manager mais en
même temps j'avais pas les moyens de
d'avoir un manager puisque j'avais pas
notoriété et j'avais pas de contact dans
le milieu du showbiz j'avais zéro
contexte donc je pouvais pas faire de
téléréalité je me souviens qu'à l'époque
et Dieu merci heureusement que j'ai pas
fait télé-réalité mais je sais qu'à
l'époque je voulais faire de la
télé-réalité donc un matin j'ai craqué
je me suis dit je vais faire un braquage
des réseaux sociaux et là je suis partie
j'ai cliper sur les chambres j'étais
petite genre j'avais 18 ans du coup je
suis partie au studio genre je me
rappelle j'avais vraiment pas les moyens
j'avais même pas les moyens de me payer
un sujet d'enregistrement j'ai dit j'ai
dû emprunter de l'argent à des potes à
droite à gauche et je me rappelle
j'avais un Vespa j'avais un Vespa rouge
et genre j'étais parti au sujet
d'enregistrement et j'ai enregistré un
son et ensuite après je suis parti
Clipper genre j'ai pris un caméraman de
trois caméras Man au total j'en ai eu
pour 200 balles voilà c'était assez
abordable et puis du coup voilà j'avais
besoin juste de d'un maillot de bain et
j'étais en maillot de bain sur les
Champs-Élysées
on a besoin de quoi d'une page Panamera
enchaîné j'ai commencé à rapper dans des
laveries j'ai sorti d'autres sons il y a
un moment j'étais une traîne TikTok pour
ceux qui ont la ref ouais je me vouvoie
tu me tapes pas la bise aussi allez à
l'époque je m'embêtais vraiment les
couilles de tout j'étais vraiment je
m'en foutue que au final je bosais
malgré moi en fait c'est vraiment ma
personnalité qui faisait la différence
et ensuite les followers ont commencé à
grimper grimper grimper mais aujourd'hui
c'est c'est voilà c'est vraiment ma
passion le rap et je suis super bien
entourée avec des professionnels et là
je passe beaucoup de ton studio donc le
prochain défi c'est un braquage musical
alors pour l'histoire de l'eau de mon
bain donc du coup je me faisais chier
chez moi et je me suis dit bah je savais
pas quoi vendre et je me suis dit
pourquoi pas vendre moi vu que je suis
une adepte des bains des bains de minuit
dont je me fais vraiment du bien et ben
je me suis dit pourquoi pas vendre l'eau
de mon bain de base c'est parti d'un
délire c'est parti d'une blague et je
voulais faire une un petit prank à vous
abonner donc du coup le lendemain je
vois closer publique plein de magazines
plein de presse parler de moi et donc du
coup bah là après de là je comprends
rien je me dis mais c'est parti loin là
le délire et donc du coup bah après même
pas 24 heures après je vais chez Cyril
Hanouna et là après bah c'est là où
clairement ça fait le buzz en fait le
buzz est parti tellement loin à tel
point que j'ai eu la répression des
fraudes qui m'ont envoyé un recommandé
chez moi et là franchement c'est là où
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait c'est
parti loin alors donc du coup mes
sources de revenus principales c'est bah
je travaille avec des marques je fais du
placement de produit après je vais je
suis souvent présente sur mime et anisan
donc c'est des plateformes où bah tu
peux revendre des photos sexy alors
pourquoi donc les gens s'abonnent à mes
plateformes alors que je suis sexy sur
Instagram etc en fait ça n'a rien à voir
là c'est plus personnalisé donc les
abonnés peuvent directement rentrer en
contact avec moi déjà c'est un privilège
voilà moi je vous suffit de la télé je
suis pas accessible alors moi j'ai
vraiment des demandes hyper farfelues
j'ai demandé des dingueries des
dingueries vraiment genre des fois j'ai
des mecs et tout ils m'envoient leur
donc ils m'envoient pour que je puisse
noter leur alors c'est vrai que j'ai
parlé sur TPMP comme quoi que je vendais
des immeubles alors faut savoir je me
suis mal exprimée quand je dis que je
vendais que je vends des immeubles c'est
pas genre je vends des immeubles j'ai
des immeubles je suis propriétaire en
fait je sous-traite avec des agents
immobiliers à Dubaï et en gros enfin je
vends des business plan je vends des
appartements je vends des villas mais je
ne vends pas des immeubles c'est à dire
voilà en gros je soustraite je prends
une commission c'est comme un parrainage
en fait du coup bah sur le coup j'ai dit
ça mais en tout cas ça a bien fait rire
la France mais après voilà c'est moi
quoi moi pour les personnes qui se
disent que je fais mal au féminisme
parce que je m'habille de manière sexy
etc justement en fait je suis une femme
nous les femmes on est censés être libre
on n'est pas censé
préoccuper de comment on doit s'habiller
en fonction
du regard des hommes du regard des gens
mais surtout je regardais hommes donc
moi par exemple si je marche comme ça
dans la rue alors que on soit voilà je
suis sexy mais bon après je suis une
femme je suis libre justement donc moi
je veux faire ce lait comme ça
maintenant je me fais insulter je vais
avoir deux trois branleurs deux trois
connards qui vont m'insulter donc c'est
pour ça que sur TPMP je retiré mon haut
c'est vraiment pour protester et pour
montrer tout simplement que nous les
femmes en France on est libre
merci juste je pense que vous allez je
pense que vous allez avoir un appel de
Gilles Verdez et voilà c'était vraiment
un message assez féministe alors moi
c'est vrai que j'ai aimé mais à la fois
aussi détesté j'ai beaucoup de haters
faut savoir que moi franchement
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] clairement vous me
faites du bénéfice il clique donc du
coup bah forcément ça génère des enjeux
financiers derrière donc
donc continuez à cliquer aujourd'hui moi
je ne cherche pas du tout la téléréalité
ça ne m'attire absolument pas et
heureusement qu'à l'époque finalement
bah j'ai pris une autre direction parce
que la téléréalité ça me correspond pas
aujourd'hui j'ai tellement de contacts
je claque des doigts comme ça et si je
veux je peux faire de la téléréalité
demain mais ça ne m'intéresse pas je me
suis faite toute seule je ça a été très
compliqué je me suis produite toute
seule donc j'ai pas envie de d'avoir
l'étiquette de la fille de télé-réalité
or que je vaux plus que ça je suis une
artiste j'ai du talent pour moi les gens
télé-réalité n'ont vraiment aucun talent
ils savent rien faire ils savent pas
lancer de concept ils savent pas écrire
de son ils ont ils ont vraiment zéro
zéro talent donc du coup non pour moi je
me concerne pas comme candidat de
télé-réalité j'ai pas d'amis dans la
téléréalité et je les apprécie pas
vraiment donc je les ai tous clachés
d'ailleurs pendant le confinement donc
donc non je les aime pas franchement
pour les gens qui veulent percer alors
si j'ai un conseil à vous donner
franchement soyez forts
psychologiquement faut vraiment avoir la
tête sur les épaules parce que c'est
vraiment un milieu assez compliqué parce
que même si vous êtes très politiquement
correct et vous aurez toujours des gens
qui vont vous insulter parce que vous
exposez donc on peut pas plaire à tout
le monde et sinon français voilà